Hey, everybody. This is Walton Gaggins. I'm the guest on Smartless today. And I can't wait to have a conversation with these three fellows. Only one of them know that I'm going to be here. So let's get this conversation started. Thanks for listening. Welcome to Smartless. Smart Less Smart Less Wait, who's guest is it today? Shut up, Sean. Jason's, you can tell by the attitude.
Fuck you, piece of shit. Hey, look at Wills on the fucking Western sets. It looks like you have his smoking jacket on. This fucking quilted, self-stitched. What's it called? Santa Fe, something. Yeah. Will, how much research?
So Will's doing a Western thing. Not a Western. What is it? It's with Michelle Pfeiffer. Yes. He's reprising. By the way, our friend Michelle Fifex
who said to me, it's Mishy Fee. And they said, I said, she goes, I know we've got to take a break so you can do your podcast. She's being sort of coy. She said with a mocking tone.
Yeah. And I said, I said, yeah, She was very good on the show. I said, you were great on the show. We loved having you. And I hope you got good response. And she said that people came out of the woodwork, too, and that people listened to it.
So how about that? That's nice. People always say, I don't want to do the show. And then they're happy that they do the show. That's right. Oh, I don't know. I don't know. Don't you feel like we just all slept together
in the same cabin somewhere because we just did this like 10 hours ago? I know. You mean? Like we just all. Well, let's go back to you. Why is everyone sleeping in a cabin? Oh, because I'm dressed like I'm in the cabin.
Well, no, well, that we just all slept in the same house and then we just woke up for breakfast and then we started doing this again. Yeah. Wait, what is your dream? You know what was for breakfast? Sushi, I just said sushi. No, you didn't.
Yeah, I went to Zabars. You know, Zabar is really close. Oh, yeah, famous for their sushi. Zabars is making sushi. It's true. I put a jacket on, I went next door, and I ate some sushi. I mean, I brought her home. I brought her home.
Hey, you shit pig. remember yesterday when you said i just had chinese food i thought to myself self that sounds really good and so i ordered some chinese for me last night oh you did how about that i had chinese for the first time in a long time right was it good that's right what did you have i was wondering about your face because i i could see there was something you know will um wait till you see my face after uh sushi lunch today yeah wait do you get um do you get like you know anything kind of naughty When you order Chinese, like breaded chicken or breaded something or is it all like a bamboo shoots and, you know.
No, I, we had a couple of chicken dishes and a noodle dish and there's some vegetables. Yeah, you got to do it. You know, because I said to Amanda, I said, you order baby. I don't want to, don't let me see anything on the menu because I'll order, I'll order Sean's food. And she went like totally clean and everything right. Yeah, and it was good.
And it was great. All right, wait, Will, one of the grossest, images I ever witnessed in my life was going over to Jason's house and he's swimming in his pool in the backyard while Amanda has a big hat on covering the sun
and from the pool on his floaty he goes honey can we get some sushi for lunch while he's baking in the sun it's so Hollywood gross he facetime he went floating on a floaty in his pool I was like at and I was just
all I thought about was like obviously Ernest Borg9 in the pool because he would be by the way by the way by the way by the way it just reminded me I forgot to tell you so a little while ago I run into Griffin done our old pal Griffin done the great Griffin done the great Griffin done so so Griffin done so he says I've been meaning to see I've been meaning to tell you this story been meaning to tell you the story he said years ago when this is public record
he said when Ernest Borgnine was getting divorced his wife cited one of the problems that she cited in the court record was of their differences that she found that as a problem as grounds for divorce
was that Ernest Borgnine would Dutch oven her he'd fart in the bed and pull the covers over her head Is that real? Is that real? Swear to God it's apparently and I looked it up, it's true. And she hated it, and she was disgusted by it. And so he was like, I got to tell, Will, I got to call him.
So he had my old phone number, because I haven't spoken to him in like four years or something, and I switched my number. So he keeps, he's sending me stuff. And he calls me, and the guy goes, hello? And he goes, hey, listen, now, you know, this thing about Griff, you know, he goes, hey, well, and the guy says, sort of says, yeah. And then he goes, listen, Ernest Borgnein, and the thing, and the reason he got divorced, and the Dutch,
chubbing this stuff and the guy goes this isn't well okay he's changed his number and that is it disgusting why would you think i'd want to know this disgusting and hung up on my god that's really funny uh my listener as a backstory you should know that um i bought ernest borgnine's old house years ago years ago and uh will has been writing me for years that what i've done is i've made a bad purchase because not a bad purchase well when you consider consider that supposedly Ernest Borgneem was a world-class masturbator. Well, he credited his longevity with the fact that he claimed that he masturbated every day. So I've always imagined him everywhere in the house leading against the rail.
I don't know why it's a good shack. Yeah. And so it's in the pool too, Will, and there's also lots of farts stuck in the master. Okay. Got it. Yeah, and when Ernest Borgonite, no, no. That is crazy. Welcome to SmartLus.
So I've been meaning to tell you that. All right, let me pull up my notes here. Oh, yeah. It's organized. All right. I've written a little intro. Where is it? Here it comes.
What we've got here today. So smooth. Oh, God. Stop shouting. Well, we're back from commercial. What we've got here today is an actor, an exciting actor. this guy knows how to put you on his back
and carry you into the world of some pretty interesting characters. Some are funny, some are scary, some are dark, some are breezy. Whatever it is, though, it's always a good ride. He's the kind of actor that gives you the grin of expectation and the feeling of relief that you're in good hands for wherever you're going.
Guys, I write these myself. He was born in Alabama, raised in Georgia, moved to Hollywood at 19, and has brought us iconic roles in films like, Django Unchained The hateful 8 and on TV's given us gold in shows like the shield
justified vice principles righteous gemstones and recently white lotus and fallout dudes here's Mr. Walton Goggins Jr. Yo man here he is now we get it started
I didn't know that you had to masturbate every day to lead McHale's Navy you got to get the evil out if you want to stick around a while damn it I wanted to get that show. Why do you look so sharp today?
Do I look sharp? He's in the middle of a junket. Yeah, in the middle. Day, day, I think, three or four, something like that. Yeah, really, man. But this is the first one for today. So I had a cappuccino, so I'm doing okay. Yeah, you got to be fresh.
This is for fallout? Yeah, for fallout. Yeah, this is fallout. Yeah, yeah. And I knew, you know, I know that there's a surprise guest, and I saw Will the other night. I know. Did you keep it zipped?
You were so good. Well, I didn't know who was, I didn't know who, like, invited me. Dude, you were so good, I had no idea. I mean, I was focused on your full-length leather coat you were wearing, and it was 100 degrees in that room. So was I, because I was sweating. I lost 10 pounds that night. It's great.
Oh, my God. Hey, so here's the deal, MGT. Maybe we've just sniffed out what the, maybe the hole is sometimes when every once in a while, Walton, a guest will come up to one of the three of us. and say, hey, can't wait to see you next week. Or the rep. Or the rep or something like that.
So what I think is the guest needs to be told, Michael, who the hosting fella is. They're told. The rest are told. They are told. We're keeping that in. We're keeping that they're told in. The host, I mean, the guest knows who the hosts are.
This is smartless, man. No, no, but you didn't know. Your people didn't tell you. Yes. Yes, that's right. You know who we need to be speaking to are Walton's representatives. They get them on the phone. Yeah, we're going to get some of them are in the room right now.
Do you hear that? Why didn't you tell me, honestly? It doesn't matter. It's truly just to cut down on homework for the other two. What's up, fellas? What's up, bud? It's so good to meet you. So you're out there with the sandwich board for Fallout.
I am. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. We're just starting. And how are, let's just jump off right there. How are you enjoying? God, he loves to jump off. What's the pre-call? I love to jump off.
What's the pre-call on that? You got a two-hour pre-call there for the makeup chair? Yeah, man. It's like three hours, you know, before anybody else shows up. I mean, it got so bad, like, not so bad, but we were, we filmed the first season in New York. Yeah. For some reason, honestly. Well, because you've got a place there, a beautiful place there in the Hudson Valley.
They thought maybe we'll make it geographically. attractive for Mr. Guggins. But never saw it. I never left the city, really, except to go to Namibia. But we're out here now, and we were out filming in the desert. I've got this van, you know,
that like so many other people. That you rent back to the company and you call it your dressing room? As a matter of fact, I do. Wait, what? It's working. Yeah, here's what you do, Sean. What are you talking about?
When you're a fancy pants like Walton and you're working all the time, the smart money is spent on like a motor home or a van or something like that. You buy it yourself. Yeah, and then you rent it back to the production as your dressing room. And so they give you the money for dressing room rental.
It's all pays for itself. It pays for itself. Kind of. Yeah, I mean, it's a little harder in New York than it is in Los Angeles. Parking on 8th Avenue. Yeah, parking is very expensive there. Parking tickets offset the rental fee. Yeah, but it did.
It worked out, you know. It worked out. But so we got to a point where we were kind of filming like out in the desert a few times. And then I just stayed for the first time, I don't know if you guys have ever done this, but I stayed at base camp. You slept in your trailer overnight?
You know, really kind of bad hotel rooms, like in the middle of nowhere. You slept at the location. Yeah, at the location with a security guard. Everybody else leaves. And I just had my food. Did you stick them for the hotel money too? Give me that?
Yeah, I got those $60. Yeah, I said, no, come on. I love it. Let me have that chair. And you have your shower and a little kitchen in there and everything. Yeah, everything. And it was only $60.
four steps to work. You didn't shower there. I mean, I had, yeah, I did shower there. Did you? Yeah, as a matter of every single night. Yeah, of course. I mean, you got to shower when you had that stuff on your face.
Jason would never use that water. You'd never use trailer water, right? Yeah, no, exactly. I don't want to smell like a hose. I have filtered. I only use. But, Walt, you do strike me as a fella, you do strike me as a fella that is not
afraid to walk barefoot on a hotel rug. No, no, I'll walk barefoot across a desert. Exactly. You're a guy that you're much, you're not, I'm a soft, I'm a soft man. You don't seem like a soft fella at all. You can handle quite a bit of, you know, taking away the creature comforts. You know, well, I just, I had an experience where all the creature comforts were taken away. Like, and I didn't realize how, how many they were going to take away. But I took my, I'm a father. Sure.
To two of the parents here and Sean, you have a dog. I know that's, yeah. You know, I just have one, so I can kind of, you know, not take a job for a while. But I took him, he was 14, right, about a turn 15. And it's like, okay, well, we, you know, this is a big transition kind of in your life, and we need to mark this occasion. And I took him on a two-week horseback riding trip across Western Mongolia. Oh, wow.
Yeah, no, it's a big deal. It was a big deal. He's 14. He'll be 15 in about six weeks. and it was just an opportunity for us to kind of get out there and see the world and we're both obsessed with Genghis Khan Jason would be stressed
going to the first class lounge in Mongolia like that would be actually where are you going to find a TV with CNN International or coffee pods or anything like that when you're a signal man but where do you again you do strike me as a guy who's so
sort of there's a lot of texture in your life I'm like I'm surrounded with thread count and things like that I like well I like thread count too you know but you know how to do both Mongolian Kashmir
I mean I like all of those things but on this trip here's what here's what happened and other than maybe we'll get to like a parenting moment you know with my son which was extraordinary but on day three I mean it took us
it took us about like 72 hours just to get to the starting point, you know, and stopped and missed a flight, spent the night in Istanbul, which is, you know, hey, throw me in the briar patches. I loved that place. And we made it to Alam Batar, then another plane landed in Western Mongolia, and then like an eight-hour drive to just the starting point. We got there, and it was just the two of us. We're obsessed with that part of the world, and then we start, you know, we meet everybody.
Nobody speaks English. We have an interpreter. It's just the two of us, five horses, I mean, seven horses, five camels. And an interpreter, two horsemen, an eagle hunter. Who sets this up? And a cook, man. Like, it's legit. It's the real deal.
Wow. And we're both, like, in the tent, the first night looking at each other going, like, we're here, man. We did that. We did it. And the very first, when we landed in Western Mongolia, my son looked at me, and he said, I've never been this happy in my life, Dad. So he's got that wanderlust like I do. So cut to day two, you know, something like that kind of happened. And he, you know, was like, wow, this is, excuse my language, this is really fucking hard, dad.
Like, this is really hard. Like, this is really hard. And he was, you know, he was missing his mom and missing, you know, his life. And I said, you know what, buddy, I understand it is hard. You're absolutely right about it. It's very, very hard. And you can be in this place and I'll hold you and I'll love you. and I'll comfort you in this time.
Or you can, he said he really wanted to go home. And I said, okay, but I'll hold you and I'll comfort you. And for as long as you want, I mean, for the next 12 days. Or you can accept that this is your reality, right? You're not changing this reality. And you can let that fester and you can react to that. Or you can accept the fact that this is your reality and actually learn and not waste that energy.
Just touch the most emotion. It's up to you. And literally, at 14 years old, you see, I just need, can I use the battery? Because there's no, you don't have cell phones. We only have, you know, a little bitty batteries with us or whatever. It's like, you can use the battery if you use it up, use it, whatever you want. He's like, I just need to listen to some music. Yeah.
He did. He sat in the tent. He came out about 45 minutes later. And he just looked up at me. with this big, beautiful grin on his face. With a plane ticket. No, I'm kidding. Yeah, with a plane.
And he thumbs up. Like, I'm good, Dad, I'm good. And then, so it's like, okay, he got through that. The next morning, I'm on the horse. We're all leaving, this whole caravan. It takes the whole process of getting ready to go. And I've been riding horses my whole life. My son is an unbelievable rider.
And my horse just trips. Uh-oh. And I went down. I didn't see any. I didn't see it coming. Oh, now who's got to go home? Yeah, well, she rolled on top of me. Exactly.
Well, this is what happened. She rolled on top of me. And I was able to push her off thinking like, oh, my God, I just broke my leg. That's it. And looked down, it was like, okay, legs fine. Everything's okay. And then I went to stand up, and I immediately collapsed. Something was wrong.
Something was really wrong. And my son looked at me. He was like, Dad, are you okay? I was like, yeah, dude, I'm okay. All right. I got up on the horse. rode for seven hours don't remember it
had a couple of Advil my wife threw in a bag what I realized you know after a few days is that I broke my riff oh God and then all of a sudden I'm like taking the advice
that I just gave my son because it's like hey man nobody's coming to get you you know in the middle of nowhere there is no like helicopter coming to air vacuum out of here man meta vacue out of here you got to go you got to ride
and so it was you know another nine days. Where is that kind of... That is... Dude, dude, Jay, are you going to tell the story about... Do I have to cred now? Jay, you're about when the guy didn't have your valet ticket at the Governor's Awards?
Yeah, and I'm like, hey, man. You waited like 10 minutes for them to sort out your limo. You remember that? A solid 10 minutes. This happened two days ago. I had to talk to a bunch of people I didn't want to talk to. My tucks was sort of itchy. And we offered to hold them.
Well, and where did you get this kind of, this kind of thick skin emotionally, spiritually? Did you have a couple of good parents? Well, I mean, I think we all have thick skin. You know, it's just a matter of being exposed to it. Look, I'm a poor kid from Georgia, and my parents were divorced when I was three years old. Yeah. And I grew up around a bunch of, you know, when I say crazy. You say it with love.
With love. Yeah, yeah, curious and. really colorful, colorful southern women, you know, and a little bitty farmhouse, you know, outside of Atlanta. And, yeah, we didn't have, we didn't have anything. We didn't have, like, you know, central air. I mean, we had like a heater, you know, that emitted, I mean, like, it is the cause of global warming, like this one particular furnace that we had in our, in our house. And, yeah, we just didn't have much. And so, but we didn't, we didn't want, much and i don't know i just think growing up that way then what about all this all this privilege
and luxury and i love it elitism that you're rolling around with every once in a while you think is it getting you soft i love it yeah no uh do i do i do it's it getting me soft yeah i mean i suppose yeah right you get you everybody has a new normal but you know how to categorize it right yeah i think so yeah yeah you're still able to go to mongoli and get along absolutely yeah can i ask you some questions about that story that it's crazy I just can't leave I'm talking to three of you man
this is just so because two of you I know and Sean I don't know so yes ask me anything We went to Sean I went to Istanbul once Yeah we went to Istanbul Don't make that together
Yeah They were at the four seasons They're at the old prison That's true That is true But By you remember Like a week
A week after we left It was like a big terrorist attack You remember that? I know Like a week after we got out of it Wow we'll be right back and now back to the show
um so the the broken rib how do you get through that many days this is going to be about ribs at chin chin okay well it's really interesting you talk about no how do I get through with a broken rib yeah I get you through that many nine days what do you do with the pain and how do you heal and like what do you do
okay he's hard man he can do it well no I mean like But there's no, I didn't know what was happening, right? I didn't, and it did, you know, I got to be honest with you, man. I felt like, oh, you know, maybe this is internal bleeding. Maybe this is it. Like, I was really, I was scared, but I tried not to show that to my son. And I said when we got to this particular, the next location after that seven-hour ride. And I crawled into this tent.
I mean, they took me off this horse, which, by the way, I had the only horse in, uh, Mongolia, um, with, uh, Alzheimer's, man. Like, she, she had no idea who I was. It's like, man, I've been writing you for eight hours a day, man. I didn't stop for lunch. I'll only been gone for 20 minutes, man. Like, I'm here. Like, there's not a, I don't have a scent.
I mean, really? Right, right. But, no, I crawled into this tent and I looked at my son and I said, listen, man, I'm going to take this ad, bill, and we're going to see if I wake up with, uh, any relief. And, uh, and if it is, then I think, you know, we're going to be over. okay, everything's fine. And I did, I fell asleep, I don't even remember falling asleep. I woke up, I don't know, three hours later or something like that.
And I felt marginally better, right? Because I'd found a place that wasn't so painful, Sean. Right, thank you. And then I was able to make it out of the tent. I walked in. I mean, I'm in Mongolia. It's the best horse people in the world. You know, they had an idea of kind of what it was.
And then while I was sleeping, they fermented a bunch of yak vodka. sure you know like yak milk and so I I just I drank we killed a goat that day and and I drank this yak vodka they just when we left there for the next thing they we had these like two gallons of yak vodka so I would just like in the morning you know like with coffee and follow it with a shot of yak vodka and a little bit ad bill you can't get that at the marriott now just a mouthful of goat yeah exactly and it was and we had no refrigeration for that goat, but we ate that goat every way one can eat a goat. Oh, I can't think of anything I'd rather not do.
Just watching Jason's face. Really? Because I'm going to invite all of you on the next trip. I would have an uncomfortable time just researching that trip. You know what? Okay, this is reading about it. The websites I'd have to go to to research this would have a font and a sort of a user interface that would be,
aesthetically unappealing to me and let alone go to the country. What's wrong with me? Because my son was, you know, at this age, I said, and he's obsessed. I got a smart kid, y'all. Like he's a very, very, very bright, very curious man. I can't even say young man
because if you sit with him, you feel like you're talking to somebody's been in a mom. How old is he now, well? He's still 14, man. Like he turns, he's a New Year's Day, baby. So this was a recent, Oh, man, I just got back like two months ago, man. Well, how's your rip now?
You know, better. I mean, I got, I got, I mean, look, it was, it's such a long story, but it kind of made it, like, kept going, and day three, it took me, that's when it, like, got really bad. And it took me, like, an hour and a half just to get out of the tent. I'd wake up before my kid did just so that he didn't see me that way. So you'd go do this trip again. Oh, yeah. Oh, one hundred one, with you guys.
No. The war of us. You won't find me that. I'll drive you to the airport. That's it. What about like a safari in Africa? What's okay. Look, what's the most adventurous experience that you've ever given yourself?
Go ahead. Yeah. Well, during COVID, like right before COVID hit, I booked a Scotty thing where we were going to go on the Orient Express. It's like his dream to go on that train across Europe. And so that's like the most extravagant thing I would have ever done. But that's on a fancy train. wind up you didn't you know because have you ever done anything out in nature though
either of you guys well i did i did uh uh a days where the work schedule laugh on a night writer episode once they get in a honey wagon and honey wagons let me tell you something if you're looking to stretch out and catch a nap at lunch you're fucked yeah you are in the forest in the forest yeah that's hard yeah those those well you mean what your legs are straight up and they're they're flat your feet are flat against the wall you got the xylophon own wall that is just you're hearing everybody's business next door I don't recommend it
you remember your roommate you remember who it was some old timer bless his heart not earn this portion Jack Elam maybe might have been Jack Elam I don't think yeah I would go if it was like
you know the kids say glamping like if it was because I love to do I've done I did when I was your son's eight I was 15 I did a three and a half week canoe trip up in northern Ontario and that was 19 In 1985 and we got dropped off on the side of a road and it was, yeah, three and a half weeks of canoeing
and it ended up being a whole thing and we got way behind because the maps were so old so we had to portage every day for the last eight days. Fortage. And we had to get rescued by. We paddled into this bay and we were like, we knew we were way behind and we had to meet a bus at a highway
and we knew we were hundreds of kilometers or miles or whatever behind. And we paddled into a bay You didn't see anybody And there was no roads up there There's nothing It was way up northern Ontario And we got
We paddled around this corner There was a cabin there We saw some people there And they dropped Sometimes they drop people A lot of Americans off For fishing for a week On a seaplane
And there's a couple there And we paddled up to their dock And they're like Are you boys okay By the way I never let Mike We were all 15 And the two guides were 18 Right
So the five five of us and then two guides and we're like we're kind of in trouble and at which point the plane that had that worked for that company drove by and saw our canoes and came and he landed and he said and asked us with the situation he said okay well we'll get in touch with somebody you know there's way before cell phones and all that shit and we were like what's going to happen and then like two hours later we see a twin otter come and land and it's the Ministry of Natural Resources and they picked us up and we strapped a couple of our canoes to the pontoons and we and we took off and we got out of there. The craziest thing was at the end of this
bay, there were these two small islands really close together, and on each island was a wing. We're like, what's that? And they're like, oh, back in the 50s, a plane tried to take off it was too heavy and it didn't make it. They cheered off both wings. Oh, my God. And we're like, are we okay? And then the guy's like, you know, Bushpile
is like, oh yeah, we'll be fine, eh, no worries. Wow. Were you scared? Did you get, did you, do you remember that feeling? You know, about day, about day four of us being way behind we started to get a little bit scared it was really we were it was just we were out there and we was like nobody knew where we were and so anyway i couldn't eat when they broke for first team i had to wait until background i had to eat when background ate and i'm like guys i've got
line i'm saying a couple lines today and they're like nope we're gonna want you to stay at my size yeah stay and holding and then we'll let you know we've got to get first team through first I had to eat one back round eight. But I made it. I made it. You made it. Oh, you look great, Jay. Walton, you grew up in Georgia.
Can you say anything specifically from that area that has shaped you into the kind of actor you are today? I mean, I guess you sort of, you basically said it. It's seasoned you a bit, right? I was going to say this. I don't know if it's Georgia, but also the way that you live your life and you're talking about the stuff you do, you have such an unbelievably freewheeling style and I mean that is the greatest as such a compliment
you bring something to every sort of role that you do you bring this kind of, yeah, this life like this kind of freewheeling thing that is so fucking alive and fantastic every time you light it up man and I wonder if that is because of your background dude I've been exposed to stuff you know he's got things to draw on
look that's a lot coming from this group of men because I am such big fans of all of you. As you know, I mean, Sean, you don't, but I am. Well, that's very sweet. Likewise. I, you know, this is what, I genuinely live every day like it's my last day. And what I mean by that is, you know, I know what it's like to be hungry. I know what it's like to be cold. I know what it's like to be uncomfortable.
Yeah. I know now what it's like to wear really nice clothes. And so, like, because I've had this beautiful fun and got to wear the well, well. wear well that's very kind of you say but but i you know it's like well why why do you think these people are letting you wear these clothes i said because i'm wearing i'm like i'll never get to wear them again and that's the truth you know why you know we have a friend and i mean that and that's okay too we have you do have an allergy to buttons though and just like just like i do's got an allergy to sleeves sleeves yeah you're in a fight with the clothes you're not you're not you're not
hey man i'm taking my cues off richard gear i'm taking my i'm taking my cue's i don't you know what i did a movie with Richard, man. I did a movie with Richard. This is a few years ago. And it was with Dinklage and Bradley. And we were sitting there and it was really, really tired. It was a long, long day. And I looked at him and I said,
man, I'm so tired. I'm really tired. You must be tired, Richard. And he said, you know what? You're right. I am. I'm very tired. He said, but you know the difference between you and me? I said, no, man, what's the difference? He said, tomorrow morning when I wake up, I'll still be Richard Geer.
And you won't. You motherfucker, man. You're exactly right. You will be. So it's okay. You're okay. That's really funny. Now, all right.
So you pack up from George. You go to Georgia Southern University, I think I got that right. And you do a year there and you say, you want to know what? I think I know what I want to do. So you jump. Did you ride horse back from Georgia out to Los Angeles? Yeah, I did. I wrote a horse.
I've seen this entire nation. Yeah, I took a long way around. So I went to the northern route, then came back and they took the southern route just to get in LA. So you pull into Los Angeles there at 19. And what you start? you start the process of chasing the dream. And was it a difficult thing to get an agent and get auditions right away?
Did you have a colorful first job to sort of pay the bills during this process? What was that first year? Well, you know, I was, I was, look, we all have our stories, right? I mean, there was no way I was ever going to go to New York. A vertically integrated city was way above my pay grade. I couldn't handle that living. Wait, wait, sorry, because you thought,
New York would be too expensive to live in? Well, too expensive, but so radically different, right? And I, and I, then, you know, the urban sprawl. Well, not sprawl, no. I grew up kind of like, you know, in the country with space, a little bit of space. And a big family, a little family? No, well, I mean, I, you know, I mean, I have a half brother now, but at the time, I mean, I was really kind of raised an only child, and it was my mom and her three sisters and my grandmother.
And my cousin, who's like, you know, she's like my aunt's daughter, like my sister. And then all of these crazy, crazy southern hippies, you know, like all of these guys. I had just a lot of people that kind of came through my life. Right. So New York was too much of a cultural shock potentially. Well, you know, maybe on some level, absolutely. And I also think that I was just really attracted to the West, you know, and the idea. I'm, you know, growing up in a place where the biggest view that you have is a football field, right, because of all the pines and all the rest of it, I just love the idea of seeing from miles in any direction.
And so, yeah, I left, you know, at 19, you know, drove across country and with my dad, believe it or not. Oh, right. You know, and I had, you know, a number. But I watched, I mean, I'm not without people in my life that were in this business. in the sense that my aunt was an actress in the theater and her husband, my uncle. So I grew up kind of watching them on stage. Sure.
And, but, you know, I really didn't, I mean, I liked doing this, you know? I mean, I did like to do. I didn't know this is what I was going to do for the rest of my life. I just really wanted to see the world. But when you landed day one, what do you do? Like, how do you, what was your plan? Well, I started working, right, in Atlanta. I mean, I started working like, there was a, yeah,
like Kyle Chandler was this, you know, in this group, and my buddy Ray McKinnon, and just there was a lot kind of going on in Atlanta at that time. And I got a few gigs there. And one was a pretty big one, you know, called Murder in Mississippi. And it was nominated for like eight Golden Globes with a bunch of really great actors in it. And so I got an agent pretty quick, you know, because I'd come out kind of before. And they said, come on out. I mean, yeah, kind of that.
I mean, I don't know. They were kind of reluctant. I mean, I don't know why they took me, to be quite honest with you. But I, you know, I didn't know, I mean, I had a guy's phone number, and I, when I first got dropped off at the Oak Woods. No, I got dropped off at this woman. I met, I worked with her husband, and she was like a manager, and I actually put this, like, on my inside version of it on my Instagram, but I got dropped off at this apartment woman, her husband picked me up, and I got back to her apartment, like, right off like Sierra Bonita in Hollywood Boulevard. And, you know, she asked me to sign this paper, and I said, I just, I don't really know. I don't think I should do that.
I don't even know what I am. And she said, well, you know, if you don't sign it, then you have to leave. I said, well, I don't have anywhere to go. And she said, well, you've got to figure that out. I said, well, can I just spend the night? I'll be out of here first thing in the morning. She said, yeah. And I left, you know, first thing the next morning.
And I had an audition, actually, with a cast director by the name of Pam Dixon. And I sat, I was there, you know, four and a half hours early. and with my luggage, and she said, boy, you've been out here the whole time? I said, yeah, you know, she'll just bring your stuff inside, just hang out. And I did and didn't get the job. But afterwards, I had a phone number
from a guy that I'd worked with and I ran into it a Rio Bravo in Atlanta and I called it and he answered the phone, a pay phone, right? And he said, yeah, man, I'll come pick you up and you can stay with us. And that was kind of it. Wow. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And, I mean, I had 300 bucks, you know, in my pocket. Yeah. And then got a job like everybody else, you know. What job? What were you doing? LA Fitness. Sure. You know, 5 a.m. to 9 a.m. shift, making full bucks an hour.
Were you checking folks in or were you a personal trainer? Checking them in, man. Yeah. Yeah. Giving them locker keys. Yeah. Like, there was nobody there. Just me.
Yeah. Do you remember where that was, which L.A. Fitness that was? Yeah. Oxnard and Coal Water. Oh, in the Valley. Yeah. Oh, with the racquetball courts. I used to play racquetball in there.
Oh, did you. As a matter of fact, they did. Yeah, did they have that? Sure, they must have right there. On the L.A. River. On the L.A. River. Would you play there with Schwartz? Yeah, Johnny Schwartz.
Johnny Schwartz? Did you guys play there? He'd kick my ass every day. And where were you living at that point? I mean, were you living at the top of the Sunset Tower? That's where he kept his course. That's where you started your journey in Los Angeles. Listen, I will say, Walton, it's not surprising.
Again, I'm going to get down to what I know from you, over the years and that you, that this stuff opened up because you come at life with such a great positive attitude and it is a really great, not to get too weird,
but it is a great example of you come out, you just, you make a call, you're open, you're very positive, and you kind of get in life what you put into it. And it's almost like, I think that that lesson,
again, that you gave your son, I mean, this is all part of a bigger, if you kind of take a broader view, that you've just got this great vibe. And again, I just, it's no surprise to me, man. People want to hang out with you. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, I mean, look, look, we all have our path, right? And what, you know, how did we, how did we get that first job? How did we get a second job? How do we get a third? How did a decade later? 20 years later. I mean, hell, we have, I've been at this 30, 30 something years, 35 years. And I, and I, you know, I don't, I just don't compare myself to anybody else really.
Yeah, that's so crucial, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, and I've got, like, we have a lot of friends in common. I've got a lot of friends who are a lot more successful than I am and a lot that aren't. And but it's the same, right? Sure.
We're all the same, yeah. Yeah, it is. I mean, we really are. It is. Sean would say something interesting because we were talking about this thing I went to the other night, and Sean said, isn't it funny that no matter what, we, on a certain level, nobody thinks that they've made it.
I don't care who you are, because you're always trying to, right right you're always there's no like people like oh you made it like i haven't made it i'm like thinking about right how do i right and everybody else think they say and uh it's this great line i just saw the movie jay kelly which is pretty good uh george clini says you know that he spent his whole life trying to get something that he thought he really wanted and then he got it and then he realized oh wait it's not over i got to now i got to keep it you know it's like so no matter where you are even if you think you're there you still got to work on trying to keep it if you care to you Do you think they'll put your quote?
Do you think they'll put your quote on the poster, J.B. J. Kelly, pretty good. Pretty good. Why not? On the back? Yeah, on Sunset Boulevard. You know? There it is. It's pretty good.
I highly recommend. Can I ask you gentlemen something? Capricorn. Do you ever, do you get insecure walking into a room? I mean, yes, in general. Every day. Every day. Every moment.
Walking into a room? Walking into a room with, you know, like, Like an event or like a bunch of actors or writers or directors or, you know, like something affiliated with this. 100% of the time. I don't get insecure about status because I don't care about it. I get insecure about carrying a conversation. Carrying a conversation. Yeah.
Really? Yeah, yeah. You're an incredible conversation. No, no. But the work that it takes for me to get up to being a good conversationalist is exhausting. It's exhausting. Yeah, it's exhausting being interesting. and somebody you don't,
you're sitting next to to a table with placards with your name on it next to somebody you don't know and you have to like, start out from scratch. Hey, what's going on? Like, you know what I mean?
So I get anxiety about that, but not so much about like status. I don't care about status. No, not anymore. Weirdly, I think it's a, I think that I'm just naive and I don't know what it is that I'm blessed with that.
It's kind of, you know, they're just like, I just don't have any sense. Yeah, I had a really cool, I was doing this interview thing the other day it's going to come out but that um and i was i had the pleasure of sitting next to benito del toro and uh well that's somebody i would like to sit next yeah and the woman said uh she said you know this idea of imposter's syndrome she said do you ever um do you guys ever have the
suffer from imposter syndrome and she said benicho and he goes what is that and i was like oh man that's wild that's so dope and she goes no you know that thing and he goes I don't know what that is. I was like, fuck. Yeah. That would make me feel even more of an imposter. But it was so dope. It was sitting me over the edge.
But at the same time, it was so cool because it was such a great sort of lesson of like you don't have to, right? Like you can try to, you can kind of let that go. And he has it naturally in the most beautiful way, but like, oh yeah, you don't have to have it.
You know? That's right. Yeah. Yeah. You know, I've gotten aware, like, you know, I've just gotten, And it scares me a little bit, you know, but I've gotten really comfortable at work. Yeah, it doesn't, you know what I mean?
And I, and that's not a feeling that I'm comfortable with. I like to be, when I'm working, I'm not very social. I'm alone. I'm just off doing my thing. Yeah, I like that. And then you kind of come in. I don't hang out and just small talk. I don't have the energy.
I'm like you, Sean. I get exhausted. Yeah, me too. I'm an introvert for sure. sure yeah yeah but you know what david you know famous david i just looked it up the david bowie it's i love this it's you probably know it aging is an extraordinary process whereby you become the person you always should have been yeah so all of this stuff that we're talking about i think the older you get the more you're like i can walk into a room because who gives a shit like i just had
i just had an extraordinary i just had an extraordinary experience and i who knows it will translate but i am up here doing this thing where are you by the way man i'm in i'm in i'm outside of i'm in montes outside of Bozeman, Montana. He's in the back of an in and out. And I'm doing this. I have the pleasure of doing these scenes with the great Michelle Pfeiffer. Jay, what do you call her?
M-Fifee-Five. Mishie-Feefe. And she's so brilliant. And I just had this moment, and I think it's age. I don't know if it's age or what it is. And I could just say it, honestly, that I was just there doing this thing, and we're literally shooting on the edge
of this river that's out there, this beautiful. It's just, what I'm looking at, is insanely beautiful and then snow cap mountains in the distance and the thing and uh we're about to go and i'm like what am i doing in the scene and what am i doing and i just went like oh man i literally was like anything can happen just enjoy just be right here yeah and then it was just like unreal yeah i'm just like letting go and i don't think i could have done it as a younger man and i think that as i'm getting older i've just let go of so many hangups so yeah because well because you asked that do you have that because you asked us that do you have
have? Are you still? Well, I guess what I was kind of getting at, just to hear your experiences. Yeah, I think that I just carried so much of the people that I've gotten to play. You know, they're pretty lonely, you know. They're, you know, nefarious, and they've got a lot going on, and they're under a lot of pressure mentally and emotionally for the most part. And so I quite enjoy kind of being in that state. place, especially, you know, at work.
But, you know, something happened recently where, where it's similar, but I just showed up like, yeah, hi, how are you? And I was just not, and I was there, I'd read the script 250 times. I know what's happening. But I, all of a sudden, I just didn't need that anymore. I mean, it's like the difference between, you know, your 20s and your 30s and then for me becoming a father at 39, so let's call it 40s, and then learning how to be a parent, oh god oh god now i'm a parent i'm in my 50s and i'm and that's okay i'm i know how to be a parent
yeah i feel like i i i know how to tell stories and i just enjoy it more than i've i've ever enjoyed it so it's just a new experience for me right like i don't i don't have that but it's freeing though right it is so free man yeah i love it is it's so free i love it we'll be right back and now back to the show well do you feel that um because you know we're we do this thing where we're playing people and i think i think all four of us are interested in playing people that that don't have it all together people that are that are that are somewhat broken and an interesting way and vulnerable and human and have flaws and all that stuff and have you have you felt like you've you know
we're talking about as we get older we get better right Just as people. So do you think that that's at odds with playing characters that don't have it all together? Like, as we're starting to get our shit together as we get older, it's sort of at odds with playing characters that are a little bit broken. And then, in fact, as you get more and more successful maybe,
you know, as we were joking about earlier, you kind of get a little bit soft because things are sort of privileged around you and luxurious and stuff. Is it, do you fight that? of embrace of success? Does it go against what you like to live in? You know what? That's a great question. I would ask you all to answer that question too, but because I think we're told a lie
early on that you've got to struggle, you've got to live in it. You have to be fucked up to play fucked up people. The truth is, no man, you don't You can just be really evolved and not create distance between yourself and that experience actually really empathize with these people. And I think that's where I've gotten to in my life. And outside of, I generally empathize with human beings. I believe that all of our paths are by nature narcissistic. We cast ourselves as the antagonist and the protagonist and our own.
story and we just watch how we interface with the fucking world. When you step outside of that, when you really step outside of that narcissistic DNA quality of survival, all of a sudden the world just becomes, it's just easier. Life is easier.
It's just calmer. And I'm calmer. And I feel that happening kind of in my professional life. It's happened. God, I had such a hard time. I I'll watch you guys on Kimmel, you know, the three of you on Kimmel.
And I listened, I saw you, Sean, and I saw, like, how far, you know, you sat and kind of speaking about your anxiety. And I had, I still have it on, you know, on some level, but I had it. I really had it. It's also a little bit of a superpower, but yeah. It is a superpower. And getting ready to walk into a room for people that experienced that, and it's like, okay, I'm going to show, because I show up for shit.
You know what I mean? I show up for a conversation and nothing is half-ass. That's right. I show up for everything. And if you put that much into it, if you care that much about it, well, then it's not performative. It's not a performance. But it takes a lot from you.
And on the other side of that, you know, you've got to just be alone and quiet and kind of do all of that. And I envy people that can just fucking move through it, man. Right, without expending like a ton of energy and still be just as charming and all the rest. I know. I know me too. Yeah, but I wonder if that, because there have been times when I have been less insecure and really kind of just cruise through it and not really. And I just don't feel like, well, I might have a lesser level of anxiety. I just don't feel like I'm participating as much. I don't feel like I'm feeling the day as much. I like I like being insecure in as many things and situations as I can. I just feel like I'm a little bit more eyes open. ears open, heart open, if I am, like, I worry when I get too comfortable. Anyway, all right, so you, so you come out to L.A., you start working.
Do you remember what that job was that gave you a little bit of like a, oh, wow, I think I might be able to make a living at this. Some people have raised some eyebrows. I'm getting some calls. Was there one that kind of initiated the momentum that you've kept going? since then? Yeah, yeah, yeah, very specific, right? We've all had many before this happened and after this happened events in our life.
And I Valley Parked, I sold cowboy boots, then I became a personal trainer at the same gym that I started this thing, I did all of that. And then I got this movie called The Apostle with Robert DeVall. Oh, my God, so good, you're so good, and I love that movie, you were great. But I was 24 years old. And it was through the process of kind of telling that story
and the relationship that I had with Bobby on the other side of that that I felt like, okay, I can, you know what, man, because I always were. And I worked as soon as I got here. I was very, very fortunate. And I, you know, poor kid, Georgia, I just squirled it away, always. And just lived off whatever I made, doing whatever job that I was doing. But at that point, I thought, well, you know what?
I'm just going to, I'm not going to do that anymore. and I'm just going to, you know, focus kind of on this. And then, you know, I don't think people really knew what to do with me because on the other side of that, thinking my manager, who was actually sitting here was my manager then. Nice. And she, you know, leaned in my ear or somebody that she was with leaned in my ear and said, hey, man, your life's about to change.
That's good, because it was a Toronto Film Festival or whatever. And then on the other side of it, people just thought, well, this guy's just fucking from there. They just got like he's just a local hire. Oh, they thought you weren't even like, you weren't even like an actor. You were a real. Yeah, exactly. It's like, oh, okay. What a compliment.
Well, I guess it is to Bobby DeVall, you know, that's what he says. But, and then I just kept cruising, you know, I just said yes in life more than I said no. And I, you know, my 20s weren't under a microscope. I just got to do my thing. Yeah. But now, but now when you walk down the street, you're getting stopped. Yeah. And you have, you have been for, for years.
but how is what's your relationship with with that um do you feel like those are two separate people the the person that the public uh recognizes wants to talk to or have you have you have you been able to incorporate that into what seems to be an incredibly authentic person from the very beginning you've you've been very tapped into keeping it real not being full of shit no artifice um no veneer uh yet the public basically has a say on who they think you are as well. And sometimes fame, there's a, there's a, there's a, there's a, there's a discomfort with, with, with merging those two things.
Have you, have you made a fan of that or, oh, you know what, I honestly, and I, whether you like it or whether you don't, whether you don't, whether you like me or you don't like me, I am me. Yeah, yeah. And I, I am me privately. I am me publicly. Anybody that knows me very, very well listening to this podcast would say, yeah, He's the exact same.
And, like, you know, interfacing with people on the street, this is no bullshit. Like, no, because editing yourself everywhere you go is exhausting, too. It's like, oh, I got to be this person who's not full of shit, who's no BS would be at a dinner table and enjoying your conversation with your friend. And then a fan would come up and ask for a picture or something. The person who's like, truly no bullshit would say, hey, man, I'm having dinner. I can't do that right now. But this is like an example.
Kurt Russell would say that. Kurt Russell did say that. He called somebody out who said, like, I'm a pilot. And he's like, no, you're fucking not. You're not a pilot? Tell me about this thing. But that's not my personality. That's not where I come from.
That's not how I was raised. And for me, and I really mean this, man. When I'm stopped on the street, yeah, I mean, it has been a lot. And it has been a lot over the last two or three years. But honestly, man, I feel like I can provide for my family. It just means that somebody else is going to hire me. And we have a public job. That's part of the job.
It is part of the job. And I genuinely love meeting people. I don't, I don't, I don't, I don't, I don't, I just, I don't, I live my life differently in that way. And I, and I don't, I never meet a stranger. I like, you know, even where we live now, which is radically different than where we've lived our entire life. You know, I wasn't, my friends are the painter and the plumber and then, and the artist and all the rest of it. But that's, man, listen, I was raised in a household with crazy fucking southern hippies. Yeah.
Crazy. Like, insane. And with love. With love. Yeah. Oh, absolutely. But certifiably and insane in the best way. And we all are.
Like a Christmas at our house, like, you know, one little heater or whatever, more often than not, somebody would go to the store and then whoever went to the store would come back with. with three or four people. And that would happen to a couple of people would come back. So then all of a sudden, like in a family of whatever, there would be like 25 people sitting around our Christmas tree
that were, you know, when we had food. And then we would go, because we didn't have gifts for them, we would just go pick out, you know. I remember giving my Atari, like pitfall game to somebody. Just like my mom said, just go in there and pick out something you can give away. And I went in and wrapped it up in a, Christmas present I'd just been playing it like in like all morning and you know and gave it out like that's that's kind of what we did and and that's you know I don't know it's just kind of how I live my my life I love that way I just wanted to ask well like you know we could go through tons of your stuff hateful A Django Cowboys and Aliens the unicorn like all those great things that you've done shield and anyway it's on and on but only because it's the big recent
massive thing is White Lotus, right? Yeah. It's like, you were so fucking great in that, and it was such a great season, and the world watches that show. It's so massive. That must have been different.
And you got to work with your buddy Sam Rock. Well, our pal, Sammy Rock. Yeah, I love Sam. That must have been fun. But shooting in Thailand must have been, well, maybe not for you. You probably loved all the fucking hot, hot, sweaty conditions, right?
Lots of open-toed shoes. Yeah, just like. I would just like, You provided your own wardrobe? I went to that part of the world 18 years ago. It's a long story. I've said it, so I won't repeat it here. But I went all over Southeast Asia.
Once I got to a certain point in my life, after studying, like, I didn't party really in my 20s. You know, I was hyper-focused on what it was I was asking myself to do. I didn't go to, I mean, I went to, you know, I went to. Rocksbury. Wall of Brown Derby, right? or the, yeah, yeah, you know, all the places over in Los Felis with Elaine and, what's the name of the place? Yeah, anyway, I did all of that, but barely. And so then when I turned 30 years old and, you know, we were on the second year of the shield or after the first year of the shield, I just said, you know what, this is my time.
Now, I'm just going to finish a job and I'm going to take off and go somewhere in the world and just hang out and get to know that place. And I've done that now, you know, a Sam's family and with family for, God, I mean, I'm 54 years old. So I've been doing that for 24 years. Your passport must be a mess. But it just gives you such a richness of life that's not just about doing this stuff. It gives you real world experience. Sean and I talk about this all the time. Like having that kind of real world experience and getting out in the world is important, man.
How do you do that? How do you find something new? to bring back to the table. I try to do that too. I think, I think it's what Will just said, I have to force myself to get out of the house. So I have... I'll put on CNN International, you know,
and I'll just see how it's all going. I like to go places, man. But even like the dumbest things, when Jason asked me to go to the Dodgers game, I was like, yeah. And by the way, never been like to a Dodgers game and like those seats. But just as far as an experience goes,
it's like, wow, I have that. in my brain now. Yeah, and you didn't take the 101. You took sunset. Oh, that was new for you, too. Backroads. And it was an 18-inning game. Oh, my God.
Take the five, man. It was great, though. Now, what about, to talk, before we let you go, tell us about Fallout. Tell us about, so you've made a friend of the three-hour makeup session.
It's certainly worth it. My God, what an incredible job they do with you. Thanks, man. It's a big, you know what? We got to do this, you know, you get a call from Jonathan Nolan. You know, the first word out of your mouth is, yes, you know. Right, right.
Read the scripts afterwards. And one of the writers was, she wrote Tomb Raider, and she was a friend of mine, Geneva, DeWartreason, and Graham Wagner. I knew through some friends. I was just a fan of his, really. But it started, it was all on the page. I didn't know, like, how they would tell this story. Yeah. And it was a lot.
Like, day one was really intense, thinking, like, man, I'm too old for this shit. Like, I don't know how I can pull this off. It was in New York, and it was like 99 degrees with a heat index of like 106. And then we just kept, go ahead. No, just to say your makeup, like, it's like you don't have a nose. No. So how do they do? I do.
How do they get rid of your nose? You know, they, they, it's called CGI. Oh, okay. Oh, I didn't know. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I thought it was like, yeah, okay. Still there. Yeah, they do that like in the post.
So people see me when I do my nose. Actually, I just saw these screeners that they send out to everybody. And one scene, they didn't do the effects on yet for the crack. Oh, fuck, that's my nose. Now, do you have to act with like a tracking mark on the tip of your nose?
Yeah, it doesn't affect me because I can't see it. But yeah, everybody else. Is it like a little X or a dot or a green? It is five dots. are four, one, two, three, four, four dots. I'll send you a photo. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So we did it, man, and it came out,
and it was really well received, and it became, you know, one of the biggest shows in the world. I mean, it truly is a global experience. I mean, this game, you know, resonates so deeply with so many people all over the world, and we got an opportunity to do it again and jump right back in there. I've been on a long run.
the best pilots I've ever since the first episodes I've seen it's it's amazing thanks man did you shoot the second season back in new york too no no no we're in l.a now man we're here yeah and and it feels it feels it feels good to be back here and to work with an la crew you know to see all of these so rare to work here yeah it's so tough here in this town right now but it feels great to look out and go yeah we're back home and so we did it we did season two and look look we've all been down these roads a number of times. And you know that if you get this first season, if you can get a critical mass to like it,
and I knew it with a shield and would justify it and with like the righteous gemstones or any of these things, that you have an opportunity to do something transcendent, really. I mean, if you can play it safe, or you can go for it. And that's what, you know, everybody did.
And we're, you know, it's about, it's coming out on December 17th. That's right. On Amazon. Yeah, man. And we're really, really, really excited about it. Well, you always go for it. You always go for it.
And as I said at the top, you never drop us. You take us with you. You carry us safely on these great creative journeys that you take us on. What was the show that you and Danny did that killed me that was the other one before? Vice principals. I know Vice principals. Dude. Dude.
You killed me in that, dude. Thanks, brother. Yeah. I would, I'd give a limb to work with you one day, buddy. So my fingers are crossed for that. Same. Same. This will have to do until then.
Thank you so much for coming on the show and talking to us. Well, and you're just a legend, dude. You are, buddy. I'll buy you a glass of whatever you want, whatever I see you next. And I look forward to. Just take me on a horseback ride. You know, I got to get cultured. Yes, anything.
What if I, what if I knocked you? What if you woke up with me and my, in a tent in Mongolia. I would need a few batteries. It'd have to be a lot of batteries in there. Okay, man. All right, y'all. Thank you so much, everybody. Dude, thank you, thanks so, nice to see you. Great to see you, dude. All right, I'll see you soon. Bye, bud. Okay. Yeah, I love the slam. He slammed it. He did it. I love him. Yeah, well, I feel a little, I do feel a little seasoned, just even talking to
him. I don't need to go to Mongolia just yet. I know. By the way, those are the kind of guys, like obviously we have tons and tons of favorite episodes this is one of my favorite ones like that guy i can talk to forever that he's how great is his vibe yeah it's great he's just his lust for life is just incredible and infectious wouldn't you want to invite him over it's funny he talks about walking him in a room every time he walks in a room he lights it up and it's genuine it's not put on that's so funny to hear him say that as i said i saw him the other night he just comes in and he just has this like joie de vivre as we've got sparkle oh a little fairy does he does have spark Yeah.
When you were talking about your experience, the outdoor thing, I wanted to tell my story about my camp when I went to camp. Oh, let's hear of it. As a kid, I went to music camp at Blue Lake Fine Arts Camp in Michigan. And it was in the middle of the woods. And that's my only kind of outdoor, long-term, woodsy kind of thing. Sure. Anyway, who cares?
Yeah. But after two weeks of being in a camp in the middle of the woods, I was ready to say, Bye. Bye. Smartless. Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic
and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.